what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Alan Saki on very pumped
to be talking about social science and
AI we have Sonia schmear Godwin they're
joining us on the show
I saw you hi Alan thanks for coming on
the program thank you I'm so excited for
this yeah a year ago you were teaching
me a lot about your work and I was so
pumped uh took a little bit of going
back forth you were actually the
catalyst that goddess Lee American
Anthropological Association as well yeah
with your focus on studying humans and
behavior and then the last two years now
we've been doing partnership interviews
with them at the Annual Meeting and
they've been blowing our minds it's
awesome often an eye even diamond
anthropologist this background she is a
senior research scientist at smart
information flow technology sift where
she is a PI on myriad projects at the
intersection of high-risk tech
innovation and psychological well-being
winning government research grants from
NASA DARPA and the Department of Defense
and you can find the links in the bio
blow to her sift net profile page also
high-seas org and also her LinkedIn and
Twitter pages okay so Sonya let's start
by talking about kind of the main
research areas and we'll break these
down as we go
the first one is team dynamics and
social sensing of human and human cyber
teams under high stress yes so again
this is like very macro level
perspective walk us through this field
of study and the projects within it sure
um so keep in mind that I'm a social
anthropologist as you have noted in the
beginning here not necessarily a
psychologist or a team researcher I'm
also another computer scientist but I
have been working with tech company now
for 10 years and I'm trying to merge
social science knowledge with you know
next waves of development within the AI
framework very broadly so we
what I do or what we do as a team is
trying to see where the social sciences
can actually inform new technology
development so all of these projects
have ultimately the goal in order to be
applied and our goal to have a tool that
can be developed a tool that can be used
and they either can be used and
implemented so what I do very often is
like in the early stages come up with
some crazy ideas as to what we should be
looking at or what we could be looking
at in order to inform the development of
the technology but then also like see it
through and then tested out in like like
high-risk experimentation such as Isis
for example to get data in order to
better understand like you know how how
we work as a team for example but how we
work as an individual as well because as
again as an entrepreneur is like I'm
largely driven by personally driven by
understanding what they don't understand
and I quite enjoyed it
so the Mutulu project for example is one
such research projects that I like to
and somebody asked me about asks me
about this I like to say like I I
perform like psyops affirmation and a
secret research facility in Hawaii and
it's not even wrong even though my
funding agency probably don't want to
hear that no what I do is like I work as
a PI on so called space simulation
studies we are trying to simulate the
conditions of spaceflight or you know
either to Mars or to Luna for example
without to the moon do no surface
operations and then have like the stress
of beating environment and the confined
in you know physical environment the
social isolation have that actually be
the stressor and understand like how
people are interacting now that creates
in itself already a lot of stress and
it gives us as researchers the
opportunity to actually also have
control over the things that we
otherwise might not have control over in
an environment so it makes it what we
like to call ecologic lis a bit more
valid when we have subjects come into a
lab there's a lot of things that can go
on outside your life that might impact
the results that we see in a lab
experiment for example it's also not
very you know it I mean of course the
basic research is very important but
like it's very different from you know
looking at the desktop at specific
images and then like you record like you
know a physiological signals a star like
an angry face that you have seen it's
not that this research is not important
it's very fundamental as well in order
for us to make you know assessments
about the human mind if you want but all
scale space simulation where you
simulate literally the restrictive
environment and social setting where I'm
only gonna be around five other people
for months if not yea years at a time
and the the individual psychometric
profiles of all these people have to
dance harmonize analogy like music for
example a dance right like the ensemble
that plays together stays together
there's rhythmicity that I believe we
can pick up and we pick it up in
language when we look at like
linguistics and Crona see for example we
look at the physiological signals they
synchronize we look at microbiome
signals as well even the microbiome
synchronizes that that might just simply
be because everybody's eating the same
diet but there's also even studies that
have shown that the ear picks up signals
that can be informative of social States
pheromones for example is one such
things and I'm not the expert in that
field but I've seen like interesting
studies where that has that have
happened in movie theaters where people
are watching a movie and experience like
a variety of emotional states
you know people with know something
about toxicity in the air able to pick
up the signal in the air as to what the
audience was feeling in particular like
things like suspense or happiness and it
was perfectly synced spiritual people
sometimes call this the collective
consciousness yeah there's a lot of
interest in collective consciousness or
collective experiences all together
right and that it's all a matter of
scale right like if you if you have like
a team of six people in an enclosed
environment that's a collective already
if you have like a cultural group that's
also a collective so it is a matter of
scale but I think there's clearly you
know something they beautiful about this
experience and it can be very beautiful
or it can be very stressful and family
is another unit it's so social well but
you live in close social relationships
where you live with people that have an
impact on you or that you care about
that would be 60th the UCSD has said
that like social relationships are our
greatest stressor but social
relationships are also our greatest like
release from that stress and I think
that is exactly one of the things that
we are trying to understand when we look
at collective allostatic note yes yes
this is a very important subject the
allostatic load out of stasis teach us
about what that is
and teach us about methods which we've
talked about on the program so much
methods to do behavior changes that
return us faster to healthier happier
states of being more pleasant states of
being instead of excessively ruminating
on a mirror or stresses and the
importance of that especially in these
in close collective environments yeah
yeah I don't know how I can teach people
to you know become happier it's not the
business I mean I'm still trying to
figure it out for myself
that said I I don't even mind if people
have social conflicts because then I can
study them and I'm not afraid of that
either
but this is so crucial because how do
you create a the proper people going to
these lunar surface missions or Mars
missions these space missions that have
the greatest efficacy for success and
how do we make the not only the
biometric psychometrics for that but
also the build out the environment of
the different things that they can play
with where I think you were teaching me
about a year ago that there's literally
like simulations of like beaches and you
know they are of experiences in that so
that yeah yeah it was one of the studies
that we have been carried carrying out
previously where we have looked VR we've
used VR we are still using we are then
as a tool in order to compare the
feeling of isolation which is perfectly
suited if you live in a very enclosed
environment and you have the opportunity
to you know escape if you know the
people that you live with is there to
annoy you you just basically literally
you know don't just close your eyes and
go off into lala land but actually you
go into a virtual reality space and you
know feel like there's you know there's
something else going on or we can
distract yourself from like maybe things
that are going on let me back up to what
you were asking about these teams so in
the past very often you know clearly
even spaceflight and we are all these
all these things that they look you know
they sound cool and it's all cutting
edge of course but you very often
focused on you know the skill set that
these people have that they are
physically physically fit and these are
very very important things of course
because if we think about spaceflight we
cannot you know we have to consider
these factors that they are mentally
stable and that they are physically
stable but we have what we have neglect
that very often in this kind of research
is the social variable
how well somebody is able to deal for
example with social conflict has been
like you know we've learned a heart
whether that actually can make or break
a mission and these experiences that we
have and we all have had like when
working in a team like we said before if
like something could work in a musical
example or if you play like dungeon
Strait Dungeons & Dragons with somebody
else homeland you can have a great
experience with a small team or you can
have like a not so great experience this
is really important when you like say
like when you play the game of Monopoly
and then the person that's like losing
flips the board game over versus ones
that can harmonize better with the
process yeah yeah it's very simple or
like when you have a deeper experience
of someone's like emotional state where
do you maybe get triggered by somebody
else's move or mistake in some way in
these small enclosed environments or do
you know how to stay emotionally
resilient meditative economist help them
also grow and ascend rather than take
them down into these stressful
situations yeah yeah yeah all very good
points of course I mean there's we are
trying to figure out how that the team
can help each other because you know
this of course like stringent screening
criteria we're trying to get the best of
the best people not just for the
simulations that is but especially when
you know we're thinking about like real
space exploration and not just like
individuals living together in a habitat
in Hawaii for example yeah so of course
we look at resiliency but the thing is
that we we have very little data or very
little knowledge as to what is actually
happening happening to a person over
time over long periods of time right I
mean I can be resilient or you know at
least try to you know have you know do
the best I can on the short periods of
time when we go to work for example and
you have like a bad working Byam and and
have a team that doesn't work well you
get to go home and you know decompress
but if you are continuously exposed to a
stressful and Brian
such as in isolation in a confined
environment you don't eat these kind of
like mechanisms very often breakdown
because you don't have the ability to
withdraw and maybe recharge and that is
what the allostatic load really is like
it's a chronic stress that is that you
are exposed to and over long periods of
time this this is going to change how
you react and people very often
themselves don't even know how they
might react like and you know when when
they're like knocked up for 12 months
for example which we also have had in
the past now the next set of studies is
going to be a bit shorter which is gonna
do one month long studies because we
have a different like research agenda
here but ultimately if we think about
Mars mission we are talking about two
and a half years and so far we have very
little data about what that does to the
team what it does to an individual
living together for two and a half years
because you know we haven't done it very
often as he's not at all so the longest
was actually one year was one year long
and this is also really mind-blowing
because you do things like you have
simulated the environment to such great
depths of nuance that there's even those
the initial you know you litter they're
wearing when they go out they have to
wear the equipment that they would be
when they were on the surface they're
wearing the large months we couldn't
they have to go through the airtight
chamber and you know do the dirty off
and then go into the oxygenated chamber
I mean this is very mhm
there's this that type of stuff but then
there's also um you know like you're
mentioning today we do things like walk
when I've ended up red and when I'm in a
feel a feeling of maybe this stress this
allostatic load is building up we do
these things called like blowing off
steam where we go exercise or we go out
into nature we go on a walk
we just you know kind of like move apart
from the other person for a period of
time but when you're in the small
habitat and there's you have to like go
out to like Mars to like blow off steam
how you know there's so there's that
like what are you gonna do in those
situations you're gonna go into the
virtual world how are you gonna workout
in a small little chamber etc um and how
do you also predict the right people in
terms of like we were talking about this
last time but just if you're sending six
people do you send people do you send
six women do you send six men do you
send three women and three men but how
like do you want them to have romantic
relationships because then they can
procreate on Mars like I know this
answer why not we imagine the trip and I
mean it's just a safety risk I mean you
cannot give birth in a spaceship oh
there's too many like factors what about
birth on Mars oh well even worse like
right then there's no infrastructure
there's nothing in place I don't see
unless we have a colony okay
yes sending a couple trips with robots
to assemble the initial correct yeah
infrastructures and I don't haven't
thought that far so far we're just
trying to have people actually live
together for I mean it's it's a
controversial topic I like to talk about
it some of the funding agencies don't
like to talk about make things like sex
for example because it's you know not
public relations save but I mean
everybody knows about that that we are
all so sexual human yeah human beings
like with you know certain needs then
that need to be addressed so you know it
should be sent mixed teams just women
just man I mean the the needs the human
needs are not going to go away depending
on the team
composition some of the simulation
studies have shown that like romance can
you know improve mood of course that
makes sense however even like as all
social relationships romantic
relationships also undergo a lifecycle
and in two and a half years that could
have catastrophic outcomes if you go
past the honeymoon and then make the
conflict that otherwise might have been
minor becomes much more severe for
example so the general tendency so far
is to avoid that and have you know
people that are can cope are
compartmentalize that for themselves and
don't engage necessarily in romantic
relationships or sexual relationships
I'm not the expert in the field and know
that there are some other researchers
that look into that a little bit more
undercover again because they gets a
little controversial as a topic but I
think it needs to be talked about and
you know I'm the first person who likes
to talk about these kind of things but
and I don't have much to say
besides that with regards to team
composition that we don't have a great
understanding yet the general tendency
is to have mixed teams and that's not
just from knowledge from the mass or you
know space simulation studies but
organizational and behavioral studies
that you know if you compare it to other
data that we have and there's very
little data on just all-female teams for
example because in the past if you think
about space simulation studies it has
been all-male teams now we have realized
that women are maybe socially a bit more
intelligent so the team benefits
generally with more social intelligence
is it a all-female team would that be
ultimately better so far the verdict is
out I don't know there's a lot of things
that would speak for that but there's
also a lot of things that would speak
against that you know there's gender
differences when it comes to for example
you know depression or mental like
mental things I should say and the
depression in in order to the other part
the other part of your question you know
how how do you how can we help this team
there's it it has been reported and we
have experienced that like over long
periods of time there is certainly a
high risk of more than one individual
maybe the whole team to start to feel
depressed or what we would consider like
you know low mood or low valence and
what we can make assessments of they
have been it some some anecdotal
evidence for that which i think is quite
beautiful comes also from a study where
there has they have been like six
individuals living together and one of
them started to withdraw more and more
and there's private quarters in some of
these like isolation chambers where you
can withdraw and this one person like
was withdrawing board more and like
little severely feeling depressed and
then the the team members of that crew
had to basically intervene and they came
together and literally lifted that
person yeah physically if you're out of
their quarters and said come you a part
of us you we hold you yeah and I think
that speaks for the collectiveness of
small teams of like us as humans that
like we have these capabilities of
saying like you know you don't feel good
it's understandable you want to be left
alone but the more you are not part of
us the worse you might feel so here here
we are like we are able to care you you
know and we we offload some of this
allostatic load that you experience much
more than we do so going back to the
research goals with a current project
for example is exactly that like this
off loading and unloading of stress if
there's a person that is depressed that
is part of your team is that person
gonna ruin it for everybody else or is
the mechanism in place or where
everybody else can like actually you
know help that person in order to make
sure that everybody is going to be
okay so you're also designing
interventions to decrease our static
loads to return people to a low stasis
well right now we're just one or more
let us understand the mechanisms and
once we understand it we can then
provide maybe diagnosis and then once we
can provide a diagnosis then we can
intervene it's you know it's not as
simple as that that we say try try to do
this so yeah yeah for me it's been now
several years of interviewing different
people that have come onto the program
that have been teaching methodologies
for returning themselves to a state of
equanimity or inner peace given this
serious just swings in different
directions that we experience in life
and to hold that sort of inner state of
deep love and peace and
interconnectedness presence that is just
the most difficult almost part of
knowing yourself is is knowing how to
get back to that state because then what
happens is whether you're with family
friends co-workers people online doesn't
matter your ability to be come back to
that moment butterfly effects out to
other people mm-hmm and then it creates
that more harmonic environment around
you and around the world by doing so so
this is actually to know these
mechanisms again thousands of years have
went with people studying meditation and
this is and thousands of years also with
shamanic experiences with ethno botanist
with plant medicines we do more and more
archeology into this and we understand
that modern health care is missing this
component and so again it's one of these
things that what can we really leverage
in biology in these rich cultural
experiences that can make it so that we
can thrive better as we go on to these
space expeditions and we have these
enclosed environments
this is huge for the topics that we've
had on the program oh absolutely and if
I take off my son's head but who does my
son yeah I'd like you know I personally
very much believe that the intention
setting that we do when we meditate or
when people pray or engage in some sort
of like with the consider spiritual
experiences I think is I believe
important so even if we look at like
crew members and you know a spaceship
the intention setting is important
what are you why are you in it and what
are you in it for is it for you know
self promotion is it for you know the
good of the world if you want in I mean
these are things that might not be that
clear for yourself even because it
requires a lot of self-knowledge in
order to you know know things like that
I certainly don't know anything yeah
yeah this is um I'm really happy that we
wandered into this field because as we
design better and better mechanisms for
this we can inch
ensure an architect a more prosperous
world okay
that's a lot on high seas and so people
you guys can find more information about
that it's hi h i - seize s EAS dot org
if you want to find out more information
about that project okay we saw have a
lot more to talk about so that was
medulla i should maybe just mention that
this website is still a little outdated
because it has the high seas habitat is
currently actually owned by the blue
planet foundation which is a
collaborative project together with
actually the behavioral science lab at
NASA as well so we are conducting like a
number of studies like next year at the
high seas habitat that is not
necessarily associated with the
University of Hawaii anymore so that
website is actually reflective more of
what we have done in the past but as we
go forward it's a blue planet foundation
and also the moonbase Alliance which is
owned by the blue planet foundation and
moonbase alliance
just who actually owns that habitat and
with it like Henk Rogers who is a
prominent figure that like actually owns
the habitat but he does a lot of work
with regards to helping us understand
like sustainability not just you know in
the context of spaceflight but also like
how can we test out these technologies
of you know reusing everything not
leaving any waste behind that is
important for spaceflight but ultimately
also for the planet we live on right now
yeah actually when you mentioned Hank to
me last time as well I was hoping that
we could do something with featuring
people like Hank in this space as well I
look forward to you should yeah yeah
these types of interviews are really
crucial like what we're having right now
they they're really important because
they synthesize a lot of the most
pressing fields plus the direction that
we're going in the future and to know
how to best be efficient in that process
and reduce the ups moments okay let's do
another one in the same first point that
we were in again this is under team
dynamics and social sensing of human and
human cyber teams under high stress so
the next one is Vanessa virtual analysis
networks and explanations for social
sensing analysis okay so what casters
they're not that much to say about the
project it is a smaller project actually
and it's very related to what I've been
talking about before it's also related
to a new effort called assist so the
goal here is really try to understand
not just human teams but human human
cyber teams meaning that if we have a
cyber agent or an AI as part of the team
like how does it change the team
dynamics what would that function
be so some of the research efforts are
often going towards getting a better
understanding of that we're an AI agent
would be more or less an assistant or a
helper for a team and where we could
like offload all the tasks 2 + 7 800 AI
that the team itself is not good at such
as gathering a lot of information
identifying patterns making indifferent
inferences about team dynamics
themselves and then provide
recommendations what you were hearing it
before with regards to what kind of like
you know strategies should we provide
that is more part of that project is
like to do and I should maybe just talk
briefly about some of these senses that
we're looking at yes um um and you know
this has all been borne out of like
really NLP natural language processing
methods originally where we had like
teams or individuals write journal
entries and they analyzed like the
language that they use in order to make
assessments about how they feel that
then has like grown into more behavioral
research where we also look not just at
what is said or the written but also
what kind of behaviors people are
displaying and now we are integrating
also physiological components such as
stress measures or as mentioned before
even like the microbiome so we are
trying to combine physiological
cognitive and behavioral components in a
ultimately in an algorithm that then can
monitor teams that then can help inform
you know an AI if you want about how the
team is feeling with in our case with a
big focus on the social components and
not just the health you know the
physiological components but on the
social components of the team and then
might provide recommendations or
intervene before it you know it goes
down that there is the ultimate goal and
that's that's what we are using these
studies and these metrics from so
vanessa is really more
the development of the AI using some of
the data and so is actually a system
like this is a new program where on the
one hand like we are trying to build a
model of like collective allostatic load
with assist we are trying to build a
model of like what is generally
considered theory of mind and in our
when saying sifts viewpoint it's a plan
recognition problem and plan recognition
and is a concept coming out of computer
sciences and like give your mind that
everybody at the company that i work at
is a computer scientist and the only
social scientists there which is for me
if I translate it to you know my social
science world is a is a problem of
knowledge sharing so my worldview if you
want is informed by the knowledge that I
have and your worldview is informed by
your knowledge that you have and I have
my perspective and you if you are
perspective and we are trying to
understand each other you're doing a
pretty good job yes but I don't know I I
don't know you well enough in order to
really understand what's going on in
your head nor can I make an assessment
about what you gonna ask me next
who knows if you're gonna text if you
had to throw a number out it's probably
I know like point zero one percent about
your worldview you know something like
that well then that's makes it so hard
to have these things and it also makes
it hard to have that stream of
biometrics psycho metrics being analyzed
by an AI to make recommendations about
what to best do to decrease our static
loads or to increase efficiencies
towards goals yeah and you're pointing
at the very important problem that we
have in that space and that is the
quantification problem might think it's
relatively easy for us to measure a
heartbeat
like I've made so many posts about there
we have a stethoscope here on sir
it's on site that we listen to
heartbeats at night or each other's
heartbeats and it's actually a really
important exercise hopefully more people
around the world will chuda know you can
also listen to your gut and Yola here's
some very interesting things I would be
pretty scared actually I know knows
what's going on so there's the
codification problem of like there's
certain things that are easier to
quantify now if you think of a heartbeat
heart rate variability but then like
you've merged into language and then it
starts to become a bit more difficult to
quantify right like even we can say like
okay a positive negative if we talk
about valence but if we start to try to
understand intentions you know we can
we're trying actually to do that in
language as well it becomes much more
difficult now if we remove language
altogether and I have to make an
assessment about like what you were
thinking about just based on what I see
and maybe your body language or you know
you had neither your the size of the
pupils of your eye and we are actually
very good at that as humans because we
have evolved to pay attention to these
things but how we don't know enough
about what we are actually paying
attention to so it's very hard to inform
or provide the quantification of these
key restore NII but that's the intention
of like this one program in particular
is tried to use a lot of sensor data in
a Minecraft play actually in a scenario
in order to build and test various
theories and models that are related to
what are considered so called emergent
states where you know like the
situational awareness or like your
merges of mental models your mental
model of my mental model and then
bringing it back again to my own field
within on Tripoli gee I think this is
very important because here we are
talking again of different scales right
like you and I versus you know China and
the US for example these are also you
know different perceptions that we are
trying to make assessments about on a
very large
with very large very very abilities
within but that's a different set of you
know collective consciousness if you
want that is hard to quantify right
because traditionally within
anthropology we haven't been quantifying
anything and it's all qualitative you
know and great-great records and I
shouldn't like you know I want to point
out I believe that it is more important
than ever to have this qualitative angle
at that because you know there's a whole
area of issues if acquired if required
if we try to reduce complex knowledge
and this is something we do a lot when
oh yeah cutting yeah as you know that's
great
that's a bit like you said pointing at
that specific putting the flashlight on
I'm trying to reduce complex knowledge
into some sort of a recommendation to
augment experiences good luck I mean
this is a very very difficult one of the
most important fields that currently has
a a big spotlight on it structuring
unstructured data making sense of it and
applying it into real life to augment
our experiences damn
that one's a huge one okay so that was
on a Vanessa and on assist okay so the
second area machine learning bias and
the influence of socio-cultural context
inherent in big data okay that is
actually a good transition point with
regards to what we're we're just merging
into the field of anthropology you know
can the idea here is that you know the
bias in the data is a huge problem
generally when building AI we know all
about like the difficulties of like
training sets reproducing you know
racism or gender discrimination because
the data sets that we have which are
used when we talk about AI or building
AI or
datian systems or whatnot they are full
of buyers right so the idea here is that
can we advance anthropological research
if you want if we don't look at the
buyers is a negative but as a positive
in order to tell us something about the
you know society or culture it actually
came from and I think it's fundamentally
at the right approach because a lot of
efforts especially by the big tech
companies for example have focused on
trying to remove bias in order to really
work I considered a little bit makeup in
order to you know make them look better
or in order to improve specific outcomes
of say a search result for example that
happen to be racist but it doesn't
remove the structural bias inherent in
the data because the bias itself comes
from a social reality that we cannot
change as easily so why not go and not
try to understand the cultural context
this actually came from and what other
what are the variables that contribute
to the existence of the bias to begin
with in this case for example gender
bias because gender is a topic dear to
my heart and I'm trying to understand so
we looked at gender bias and like large
amounts of Twitter data from all over
the world literally 100 different
countries oh you went to Twitter for the
data it can say a lot of things about
that
so I should but this should say this is
well it's a 10 upon our collaboration
with Stanford University in the computer
science department for the university
and they provided us with the data in
order to analyze that so we had very
large amounts of data and would be what
we looked at is like well as a lot many
different things but the idea ultimate
goal is and was what the project is can
we can we find some sort of like causal
relationship ultimately or you know it's
very very hard and I don't know if we
really can or at least explain
nations that can help us understand
differences and like how gender
discrimination is quantified in the
language that we are analyzing could we
could we maybe say that like a root or
an upstream variable in gender bias and
discrimination maybe a if in the case of
a man maybe their relationship with
their mother things like that could be
some of the most upstream or root issues
if there was like a loving and tight
relationship between a son and their
mother growing up yeah that man will
likely respect women with great yeah
love this is a very good point and it's
not one that we look at that yes yes so
these are I'm always going to upstream
or root things be as tell us of huh
focus like that no I you know in a
different project we looked at in cell
data for example you know the in cell
community involuntary celibacy yes which
I really hope can find a a that our
society can find love to help the more
healthy states of consciousness and
being for people that are labeling
themselves this way because we can do
better I know we can do better
yeah yeah cuz I feel I feel a lot and
I'm very sensitive to things like that
and we can kind of dig ourselves into
holes by associating ourselves with
labels rather than kind of like taking
ourselves out into challenging contexts
and learning how to grow through
hardships yeah yeah okay I feel a lot to
you but it's mostly anger especially
when it comes to eating cells
I'm a woman so I'm biased that said what
my point was you talking about like you
know mother-son relationships I think
that is actually something that does
play a role in that kind of community
the data seems to indicate that um that
much I will say about you know things
like does your of course your upbringing
and if you have been taught to respect a
woman or not plays a role I mean no
doubt about that yes um but when looking
at you know on a global level at like
gender stereotypes and like how much man
was as women associate themselves with
particular gender roles that's a little
bit different because I believe that
gender is a social construct I believe
that there's absolutely a biological
reality that you know I look different
than you and my body looks different in
you but the way we behave or the way you
know what interests us that is very
often largely influenced by how we
brought up and like how we brought up to
fall into this gender stereotypes and
that in that sense looking at the global
scale is actually very interesting
because we have like direct comparisons
between countries where the associations
of the individual with a specific
janitorial stereotype is maybe a bit
more reduced in one country if you look
at like northern European countries for
example versus in other countries where
women in particular are you know don't
have the agency to make decisions about
who they want to be who you want to be
or who you want to become is a luxury we
take for granted in the Western world
but it's not a given in other countries
right so I mean there's a lot of power
dynamics and I'm drifting off like a
little bit now from the research itself
when looking there's there's a lot of
different social science here
about like like this gender roles and
gender stereotypes and one of the common
denominators at least in the social
science literature is that it is a
construct if you want that like a lot of
like how you behave or how I behave and
mannerisms that we have are actually
just learned features now that stands in
opposition to what is generally known as
the gender paradox
meaning that if if you look on the
country level and this is not research
that I have done but it some of the
research that we have been doing is
informed by that if you look at the
country level why you have certain
groups of men versus women like more you
know why is there more female physicians
in one country or more male physicians
in another country and what kind of
attributes are associated with these
professions for example then then you
have to consider the political system
and the social structure where this is
coming from yeah but then you also have
to look at like you know freedom you
talk about degrees yeah yeah like the
choice that you have yeah there's this
the paradox is that in northern European
countries where you have generally very
high gender equality there's actually
very few women that go into stem
research occupations or like traditional
like no more male dominant dominated
occupations where you have like
countries in Albania for example where
you have a high degree of women going
into these you know predominantly male
areas so we the researchers have been
trying to understand why that is the
case wouldn't it like be the case that
if you have a country like Sweden where
women can choose who they want to be
that then they would have you know more
people in like male dominated areas but
I believe it's a u-shaped function where
we have countries where
the women have may be exposed to an
oppressive system and they are trying to
become financially independent or become
independent like as as a person and they
will adapt to you know a system and
therefore also make choices that will
allow them to break free where when you
have a system where women are free to
choose who they want to be women
actually it looks like at least fall
into like what we consider more general
stereotypical behaviors and that is
considered the paradox the point though
is if you know but if you talk about
like larger collective goals then we
want to I think it I believe it is
important to provide freedom of choice
and not restricted in any way like allow
people yeah you know what do I want to
be ya equal degrees of economic freedom
to self-actualize and that's really
important and to be able to look at the
stream of stimuli that we deliver to
children from the moment that they're
born into the world and how our culture
around them shapes their decisions
because many times we talk about men
generally being interested in ideas and
women generally being interested in
aesthetic and then we also and social
and women being more interesting social
and then we also simultaneously have
shaped our civilization around those
beliefs so that then it kind of also
makes it difficult to in a sense get us
out of those ruts like if women do
decide to be interested in stem then
sometimes the ruts are so deep that it's
hard for us to dig our a way for them to
get into that just like with men if they
want to get into Social Work like
there's eight out of ten people in
Social Work being women in nursing I
enter in and there's nine women out of
every ten people that are that I'm
around all automatically and so again
there's these ruts like if I really want
to serve people in hospitals
way how do we make it so that it can be
easier for people to pursue whatever
they want to pursue in terms of having
these degrees of freedom and try and
limit the social pressures that pressure
people into specific categories but
rather have it be something that's more
like finding out what is really thyself
and bringing that forth into the world
so that in itself is interested so with
the Twitter data that was being analyzed
it was gender biases towards so what we
did is that we built a model we first
looked at Twitter data and then we
quantified the bias in the data and we
saw that there's differences in
different countries where there is
specific concepts that we can measure in
language close associated with the you
know female words if you want the
process like me love words it very
simply put so we had a way to make a
quantity we had a way to quantify gender
bias in the Twitter data so we could
like reliably say that for example in
the area of politics or in the area of
like childcare there is more or less
bias in one country versus the other so
that was the first step and what we then
also did is that we basically correlated
all this data with statistical indices
of countries in order to see if that is
actually true if it actually matched the
bias in the data actually make matters
like real-world recordings of you know
the World Economic Forum gender gap
index for example and we saw that that
is in fact the case so that we in that
way you know we were able to do a check
as well and then in that way we made
sure that this is I lost my fret now I'm
gonna have a yes yes yes so let's take a
quick moment to do that I also add you
know as you were saying of that I also
realized that a lot of the things that
I've learned in the last couple of years
about the field of of differences
between gender and psycho metrics I
would say are very yes of course
interesting to analyze the way that we
fit into the big five
personality traits but also just like
the sheer complexity of every single
person being very unique in terms of
their own into the individualistic
expression into the world also I just
want to respect the fact that evolution
is not something that has stopped and
that there's a certain way to frame like
this moment and there's constantly a
biological and psycho social evolution
that's occurring all the time around us
and that these things are never static
and so like I don't know something also
about just the way that children are
funneled into like like like blue and
pink and like like trucks and stuff like
that and dolls and stuff like that just
it all is that kind of stuff is very
strange to me and like it it's almost um
it's so binary and non nuance that it's
actually kind of scary in a sense like
that you can shape your child's life by
the purchase of a toy and like that's
really scary to me because it's it's
almost as though like it would be maybe
more given the age of the child to be
able to enter into the section of toys
that they're interested in tools that
they're interested in learning from and
having them be able to kind of look and
try and figure out what interests them
the most and then be able to choose
themselves no diversity is beautiful and
we don't quite understand that and
diversity gender diversity is beautiful
and not only that it's enriching it's
enriching us and it like provides us
with a better and not a worse
understanding and I think this thinking
is particularly important as we are
moving forward with you know the
development of AI because
what we are doing right now is very
often we reproduce a social reality that
is gender bias where we think in
thinking oh yes and we have to think
about like you know the values and the
perspectives and the knowledge that I
mentioned before when we were talking
about teams when we are building that AI
so that we don't like suddenly export if
a company like Google support like and
technology into you know a different
part of the world where the local
knowledge and the local reality haven't
been taken into consideration at all
that can like you know that is very
problematic so I think one of the things
that we have to really think about and
that that we have to think about really
deeply is how can we actually integrate
the diversity of cultural values when we
are building AI systems and we are doing
a great job at that if you look at
Twitter for example you know in even in
our own research here we looked at men
and women like in Twitter data so that's
a pretty bad example but you know we
have to of course start somewhere
but having an understanding of like
complex you know it's also like this
hype and AI like you know complex
systems and very it's very hard
mega-corporations have a big
responsibility
- I think follow us towards nuance
towards multi variability towards love
towards interconnectedness towards
harmony towards gathering in person to
explore different states of world views
rather than simply be dominated by the
corrupted business plans of the
attention economy feeding echo-chamber
style feeds and advertisements down our
throats we talk about that quite a bit
on the program yeah you had a lot of
videos already I'm the problem is very
hard to have the time to look at you
know we love we love talking about that
space that was that was you okay let's
get into let's get into the third one um
okay text analysis and how language is
weaponized to influence social groups is
kind of yeah exactly especially given
what you just said about like a chamber
so um I think that's one it's one of the
most important things to work on right
now it's like the social media space as
you know it shouldn't quote somebody
like Mark Zuckerberg but he wants to
connect people right with Facebook
that's what Facebook business is
connecting people at all costs so
there's you know are we feeling more
connected thanks to Facebook I don't
know right the that said we have here a
space where people are communicating and
for some of us that provides a sense of
like the what used to be you know a
village or the coffee at the corner
there is a virtual space where
communication happens and there is like
different influences and different
behaviors that are suddenly being
displayed there's in cells that you know
have a following and feel maybe even
stronger than they maybe would otherwise
in the real
because there's social punishment that
doesn't exist in a lot of these social
media spaces so hate speech and
cyberbullying and all these like
negative things that are happening on
the social media space have a real world
influence and they are not good right so
how the goal of this particular research
project is how can we like understand
what's going on in social media space
but looking at the language that is
being used in order to understand what
the intentions of people are in
particular negative intentions and this
is important because language is very
very powerful and language is
intentionally used in order to
manipulate in in order to influence
others on a large scale it's really a
weapon and has become a weapon and does
therefore it is so important so a lot of
money is being poured into this area
right now so that we have better tools
because there's an ongoing cyber war
between countries that is happening
right now and it's very ugly one and the
u.s. is not winning it so what we have
done in particular it's like a small
piece where we're looking again at
social science theories in order to
inform the development of tools that we
can use in order to if you want find the
bad guy but also help people that maybe
are have troublesome intentions how do
we do that there is like a wonderful
psychologist called Albert bandura
who used to be at Stanford he has
developed a theory around like what we
call moral disengagement meaning that we
are actually using or engaging in
specific cognitive strategies that we
are using yeah yeah I keep going so we
use particular
cognitive strategies in in order to
justify you know harmful actions or
atrocities if you want this is important
because we have to assume and you go
like this that in general nobody has you
know nobody is unless you're up
Psychopaths maybe nobody like wants to
do harm or nobody thinks they're acting
immoral most people think they act on
morally right yeah yeah even though we
might not agree but like I believe that
you know my actions are right for me but
how do I make them right for me if I
actually want to harm you or if I would
want to harm to somebody else what we do
then is that we tell a story to
ourselves and that story can be analyzed
and that story contains of things such
as the humanizing language or
replacement of responsibility we use
euphemistic labels which justify our
actions by engaging in in these
cognitive strategies so that the impact
this is like instilling this instinctive
you know feeling that we have that
something is wrong is actually lessened
this has happened and you know second
world world is is happening in other
like areas of the world where like
genocide is justified right now so these
are things that we can do this is being
like used by politicians if you know
they want to justify war in a different
country they're all using this this kind
of language that is full of language
that will make the harmful action less
impactful yeah when you dehumanize
someone you actually dehumanize yourself
and that's a really hard loop to
understand and it comes from a lot of
practice of deep eagle loss and ego
death and understanding agree with you
because I don't think that you'd be
humanized others with the humanized
others because we think we are humans
but they are animals they are rats
they're cockroaches they come here and
take our you know things away that we
have built so it makes us human but not
them yes still trying to understand the
disagreement because I also have that
same perspective that you just listed I
said that when you dehumanize others you
dehumanize yourself meaning that if one
gets the idea that yeah like you don't
actually perceive that to be true you
don't think you're doing that even
though you are doing that what you're
saying is like of course you DQ man eyes
yourself because we are all humans but
the understanding is that like I'm a
better human yeah I'm so much better
yeah yes yes yes I'm so much more
morally righteous that I can make this
dehumanizing statement about other
people when in reality being the one
being the brothers and sisters that we
are trying to collectively prosper on
this planet that that is a statement
that is actually when you do dehumanize
someone else you dehumanize yourself and
that there there needs to be a stronger
cohesion between each other where you
can parse words that people say on
across social platforms and you can
predict mass violence from and prevent
it from happening there's oh there's
actually a lot of really interesting
work happening in what's called like
data fusion with um fusing psychometric
data with social data and doing things
like predicting violence from occurring
and preventing it from occurring with a
crime prediction these types of things
which are which are quite interesting
fields yeah Palin tears in there a bunch
of other companies are now starting to
pop up in that field because you can
parse peoples for negative sentiment for
dehumanizing sentiment and then predict
violence and also you can also
you could potentially also try and water
people seeds with love because if
someone is starting to use dehumanizing
language if there is a way to water
their seed towards love it can prevent
that violence from happening and also it
can help them grow more down the line
where it's not like we have to put them
in prison but rather it's they
consciously evolve themselves to not
cast malevolence on other people that's
the preferred solution in the preferred
world where's it coming from
right like if is it desperation or is it
anger this you know this analysis that I
mentioned like trying to understand
intentions sometimes the harm doesn't go
towards somebody else it goes also
towards oneself in the case of suicide
for example so the place where it's
coming from
where love can help might be easier in
one case than the other if somebody you
know feels like they want to like harm
themselves and ultimately maybe jump
from the Golden Gate Bridge
love is certainly the right thing
hopefully you know to provide you but if
somebody like is full of rage and wants
to you know shoot Muslims and them all
or Mexicans at the border here too I
agreed like that love might be the right
tool personally but it has to reach them
strategically yeah tactfully yeah and
you know it's very hard to minister
college is doing a lot of psychological
profiling on like mass shooters for
example and they often there's like
specific personality traits associated
with narcissism for example that are
very prevalent so you have to try to go
beyond these barriers because you know I
I don't know
maybe I don't know enough about love in
order to understand like how love can
not just be given but also perceived by
somebody who is so troubled in there
maybe no statistic mind that they would
go out and like just randomly shoots
people yeah yet this is going to be a
growing field of taking the this
extended phenotype of ours now in the
digital sphere and analyzing it and
making recommendations for our lives
that move us in the direction towards
love yeah yeah yeah and it's actually
right here we talked about that quite a
bit you know when we talk about like the
ultimate nature of reality or when we
talk about things like love when we talk
about things like that on the program
ultimately it is right here it's right
here when you when you sit patiently
with someone else and you look at them
in the eyes and you you feel the depths
of their hearts their spirits with me
this reality you are married woman with
children but that's in general we can
flirt with each other in the beauty of
love by just doing simple things like
being present with each other in the
depths of each other psyches and just
being quite quieting the mind and just
being present with each other then all
different kinds of very profound things
occur where maybe you see some of
yourself and me I see some of myself in
you that all of a sudden we start
merging with our environment with each
other we started taking our drop and
merging it with this ocean and
then more and more like you start seeing
like Sonia as a child
her parents their parents their parents
you see Alan's child of their parents
parents parents parents and you just
start seeing different profound things
as long as your lens is trained to see
the nature of reality when you immerse
yourself in these I think um I'm very
sensitive to that as well and I'm
actually I'm actually a quite a person
or maybe just suffer from a lot of
social anxiety I don't know which one
but hey I think it's the most beautiful
thing when you really connect with
someone when you truly really connect
with someone it's so real it's also very
hard to let go of that because you wanna
hold on to it because you feel like you
know there's a the Unison re you feel
like there's a true understanding you
don't have to explain yourself anymore
that's that's beautiful but we just like
me to use that as our food you know like
me - yes like have that energy and with
us and then like ride with it for you
know as long as it lasts so I think that
this it's it's one of the most you know
it is one of maybe do you think that
it's worth living for you know you have
that again with your children as long as
you have them of course like there is
it's just a very special kind of love
yeah and you have to do with people that
you meet in your life along the way very
unexpectedly
um and that's also a beautiful thing
yeah yeah well that answers our last
question which is what is the most
beautiful oh yeah well apart from love I
would say I I couldn't do without music
I think you know for me that personally
I think that music will save the world
why
it's a creative act it's like not
language it's beyond ourselves I think I
can lose myself in music and go off into
you know other planets that you want
like right there and I think there's
just some something very deep and moving
in music that is so humane if you want
that is so connecting or that you you
never feel alone you know you always
feel like you're part of something much
much much bigger and when you listen to
good music I should say and that's
subjective so that's certainly you know
one of the most beautiful things apart
from like looking at your children when
they wake up thank you thank you thanks
for coming on the show son yeah thanks
for teaching us about social science in
AI it's been a lot of fun awesome thank
you for having me there's so much
complexity around the subject surface
yeah there's only that much I can say
yeah yeah yeah yeah and thanks everyone
for tuning in we greatly appreciate it
we'd love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below on the episode let us
know what you're thinking and I at some
point the stream cut but this has been
recorded now so you will see this so do
give us your thoughts in the comments
below on the episode about all these
topics that Sonya was teaching us about
talk to your friends families co-workers
people online about the subjects as well
let's have more conversation spurring
around the world about these subjects
when social science nai and our future
in the spaces check out the links in the
bio blow to the sift on that profile
page for Sonya also hi - C's org also
her LinkedIn and Twitter profiles go
check those out and support the artists
the entrepreneurs the leaders in your
communities that you believe in support
them and help them grow you can find our
links below to our show simulation you
can find us on paypal cryptocurrency
patreon support us and go and build the
future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world you love you very much
thank you for tuning in and we will see
you
soon peace